the disaster at the border funny kamala
harris apparently thinks so
the vice president being ripped for this
tone-deaf reaction to the growing crisis
do you plan to visit the border
not today but
i have before and i'm sure i will again
i wonder if the vice president thinks
this is funny
after blocking the media for weeks the
biden administration
was forced to release some new video
that shows crowded migrant facilities
but that's only after the media shame
them into doing it
right now we have no access to or photos
of the conditions in the facilities
even the trump administration let
reporters in on
you know supervised tours the biden
administration kept talking about
transparency and we're not getting any
transparency here
blocking access to the news media is not
leveling with the american people mr
president
kennedy i think the kamala harris
hysterical laughing fit
and she does this a lot is a coping
mechanism
it's a defense mechanism she's
uncomfortable with the questioner the
reality of what
she's being confronted by so in order to
soothe herself and
cope she just erupts in this
ridiculously timed inappropriate
laughter
and it it's striking how how odd it
is i think if you cut together a montage
of her laughing inappropriately
questions and situations it would be so
torturous uh we'd never ever
have to think about waterboarding again
when
i see that reaction it just goes to show
that one she has a real glitch
and two she's a very unserious person
about an incredibly
uh serious crisis you've got a situation
where
the children who are coming up from
places like guatemala honduras and el
salvador
they're not being accounted for the ones
who are unaccompanied you know who knows
who is taking them on that journey who
knows how many of them don't make it
and then when they get there it looks as
though she hasn't even read her briefing
book
because you know when she when she
responds with today
she seems surprised that there that
someone is asking that question
she should know considering what's
actually going on down there
greg gutfeld your thoughts yeah you know
it's weird i feel bad for the democrats
because they were
grooming kamala to take over in a year
or two
and it's looking more uh more uh
difficult than the initial challenge
it's like they
drove the car off the lot and it started
giggling
uncontrollably right when you turned
that when right when you turned off and
there are no refunds
uh but it is kind of i hate to play that
cliched game imagine if it were
republican
but if it were ted cruz or if it were
mike pence chuckling at kids in cages
a there would be violent protests b
those protests would be encouraged by
the press
c there would be impeachment proceedings
four featuring a chorus
of weeping democrats five dressed like
extras in the handmaid's tale
dana to greg's point where are the the
democrats demanding transparency
traveling to these facilities kicking
the door down
and and showing that this is intolerable
and that they care and
this needs to be fixed asap you don't
see any of that it kind of makes you
think
it was all politics the last four years
well there are a couple of democrats i
think think about henry cuellar the
congressman from the area
he's the only one he was the one who
released that video yesterday um
you don't see anybody getting behind him
to like support him
on that side and in fact i think on
america's newsroom tomorrow we're going
to have a mayor from one of the border
towns that you're going to want to see
because he's a democrat
he's had it with the administration and
he's not afraid to say so
also interestingly senator mark kelly of
arizona
he's been very quiet you don't see him
do a lot of media he's got a tough race
because he has to run again in 2022.
his team put out word that his office at
placenta strongly worded letter to the
biden administration
but you can imagine that her laughing
like that at that
on about this issue will show up in
campaign ads
in about 13 hours i would imagine
juan what do you think could you see
that in a campaign ad this uh
next next term well there's no limits on
what you can do you can do whatever you
want but i think you know
away from the caricature the woman was
on a tarmac
in florida she clearly was not at the
border so that's what she said was
obviously i'm not going today ha ha i
mean she was not
laughing chuckling at anything to do
with conditions at the board there's no
question
in my mind i don't think there should be
a question in anyone's mind that the
biden administration takes this
situation seriously i mean just think
about it
they're running advertising in central
american countries to say
do not come the cartels are lying to you
they've sent top administration
officials
to these central american countries to
work with them
to try to repair some of the past damage
and to help them stop the flow of people
out of these very threatening situations
in their home countries
and then at the border you see increased
numbers of
not only people from homeland security
but now from fema emergency management
and just today word that the byte
administration has opened another
facility the pictures that we're showing
here on the five
gee they look pretty orderly like the
kids are being checked for health
they're getting educational instruction
this is what biden's after a more humane
process do you think that you're judging
me
that's keeping with american values is
exactly what i mean
i'm in the western hemisphere congress
i'm after congress doing their job
congress really realizing that they can
fix the amnesty
you know the asylum system you don't
need it congress understanding they can
pass
legislation about border security that
deals with the dreamers that you don't
need the people
here you do because
they just say then we can have a
conversation
right now right now what you get is the
congress playing
politics instead of dealing with real
solutions
you've got the majority and and by the
way the the facility that they opened
in rio springs texas hold on kennedy
that only holds 500 children
there are 565
kennedy they are opening additional
facilities
as we speak and just to be clear
just to be clear trump had the house and
the senate and the white house did zero
in fact he damaged this situation and
made it more
more damaging now for buying
trump's fault got it we got it one oh
okay so
pay for flights to fly them in here buy
them hotel rooms
open up more facilities
from the western i'm not joking like the
vp
jesse all you're doing is trying to be
little people
who are serious about a very serious
issue
unlike the vice president it's not very
serious when you're laughing about it
ahead